hey there this is Cameron with motion
science and I am back with another quick
short little video about tracking in
After Effects now most of us all know
about the different types types of
tracking like track camera track mocha
AE warp stabilizer and track motion but
what I want to talk about today is track
mask what can track mask do well let me
show you I'm going to create just a
quick rough mask around this guy this is
for a project I just recently worked on
and just finished up and I thought it
might be cool to show you guys so I've
got a mask here set to none and when I
go up here to animation I can now select
track mask and I am just going to track
the position and rotation there's not
much scaling going on that is another
option I can track position rotation
scale rotation the skew perspective and
so forth but for this particular image
or a particular shot I'm just going to
do position rotation so I'm going to
turn this back up to full to get as many
pixels as I can on the screen I'm gonna
click start and I'm gonna pause the
video and come back when it's done okay
so I've got the tracking data in there
and if I back up you can see here the
mask is following the dude
to half Rozier yeah you can see they're
at the mass just Falls the guy so what
can you use this for well the most
obvious thing you could use this for is
if we go to stylize mosaic crank those
numbers up a little bit we can go into
the effects mosaic and under compositing
options you can hit plus and what this
will do is it'll recognize this mask and
if I go to mask and turn it back to ad
boom there you go so now I've got a guy
who's all mosaicked out let's say you
wanted I don't know whatever the reason
is but so now he's mosaicked out and the
background is not so there is obviously
a hard edge there but we could feather
that let's say this is a crime show
drama or it's a futuristic sci-fi show I
don't know but you get the idea so super
cool so it follows the mask follows the
guy and the effect follows the mask so
it looks pretty cool it looks pretty
good it's not like we had to you know
keyframe where the effect happens with
the mask so once again there we go so
that's the most obvious use for the mask
tracker if we want to just amass the
guy's face or add a different effect to
this guy maybe wanted to make him look
like a cartoon I don't know but you get
the idea so I'm gonna turn the effect
off then go back into my feather turn it
back to zero and turn the mask back to
none so now I'm going to show you a
second way to use the mask tracking
which is pretty powerful to do this you
have to have a third-party plugin from
AE scripts and trust me I am not
affiliated with 8u scripts in any way
the last video I did happen to use one
of their plugins as well this one again
is using one of the plugins but it's
just another favorite plug-in of mine so
what the plug-in is called is mask
tracker plus and we'll find it right
here
really simple plugin once again watch
what this thing can do I'll click mask
so the keyframes are selected and I hit
on the plug-in and it takes just a few
seconds to load the mass tracking data
and boom it's in the plug-in so now I
have the option to use this data to
apply tracking data to taking graphics
or anything else I want to use like move
stabilized corner pin a pre comp of skew
and perspective no scheme perspective
and so forth well I have this UI graphic
that I had previously animated that is
on my scene here and I use the word on
my scene because right now it looks like
the UI graphic was just dropped over the
top of this footage looks like a motion
designer just slapped it on top it's not
integrated into the scene and looks kind
of fake and you can tell that here by
you can see the the camera movement on
the guy in the shot and the UI graphic
is just like I said slapped over the top
it's not moving it doesn't look like
it's part of the scene well we're gonna
fix that by using the mash tracker data
that we loaded so again I'm gonna make
sure the graphic is selected going to
hit apply and you'll see that there's a
null applied to the scene and here it is
our graphic is now parented to that null
and watch what happens now
so now you can see that the graphic is
all of a sudden moving in the shot like
it was part of the shot to begin with
it's much more realistic much more
integrated well let's take it one step
further just to show you a little final
polish I would do for a shot like this
and that would be to make the graphic 3d
which it is now it doesn't have to be
the data that was applied to it as 2d
and you can see that here it was just
positioned scale and rotation and this
is a non 3d layer but since this layer
is 3d now all I have to do is apply a
rotation to the y-axis like 20 degrees
and it matches the perspective of the
guy in the shot as you can tell he's not
standing like you know straight on to
the camera he's at a slight angle so now
the graphic is at a slight angle with
the guy it looks much more integrated
lot cooler it works for me looks like a
finished shot so that's what I wanted to
show you today how you can use mask
tracking data to apply effects or to
even go beyond that and use it as
tracking data position scale rotation
etc on graphics in your shots so that's
it for this lesson I hope you got
something out of it I hope you learned
something new
leave a comment below let me know what
you thought if you liked it if you
didn't like it so on and so forth so
until next time I'm Cameron and this is
motion science